I've thought about creating this video
for a little while and I'm going to be
very very Frank and public about all
sorts of matters having to do with
health and bodies and aging those sorts
of things and the reason I'm doing this
is because I've had quite a few people
reach out to me and express you know
care and concern and well- wishes
sometimes giving unwanted advice by the
way don't give any any advice I'm not
looking for that and the reason they're
doing that is because I'm very public
about you know what I'm going through
and you know like when I had coid and
different other things that I'm
experiencing when it comes to aging and
health in YouTube in my social media and
so I get a lot of people who are
interested and um you know often times
expressing their their own uh sympathy
or uh commiserating or things like that
and people sometimes want to know well
hey what's what's going on uh so I
thought I would do a video about that
because I've been thinking a lot about
it lately as I've been going through
let's say more
challenges than usual in the last
several months and people also say well
how do you keep a positive mindset and
get things done and the answer is um how
do I do it well more or less
consistently but sometimes not at all
and so I I'll tell you a bit about that
in just a a moment but let me tell you
what's been going on this last year it's
probably been a bit rougher than years
before because I am getting older I
turned 53 this year I've had a number of
different uh matters that have had to be
addressed some of which are still kind
of pending
and you know if we back up uh about a
year and a half I had coid that kind of
threw things for a loop it you know has
some long-term effects on some people's
immune systems uh fatigue those those
sorts of matters but you know my body is
also getting older it's a year older
than it was last year in 2020 uh I'm not
in my 20s my 30s even my 40s anymore and
things are gradually wearing out and
winding down and in some respects that's
to be expected so you know I've had some
injuries in the past that are you know
eventually going to have to be addressed
I I tore two ligaments in my left knee
way back uh in the in my 40s when I was
living in Kingston uh you know it's
almost well it's I think it's more than
10 years since then and you know my
muscles have compensated for it but
things are kind of wearing out
eventually I'll have to have that knee
replaced most likely the other knee has
to compensate for it um some things are
genetic I think I lucked out more or
less in a lot of Gene stuff you know we
tend to keep our teeth we tend to keep
our hair but you know there are some
other things genetically that I'm at a a
greater risk for and so let me talk
about one of those that's kind of a
complicating Factor so I I've been
diabetic with type 2 diabetes for quite
a while and you know I could control my
blood sugar adequately for a while with
attention to to diet you know curtailing
eating certain things cutting back on
sugars and uh getting
exercise and this year it kind of came
to a head and I come from a line of
people who do have diabetes on my
mother's side my mother was diabetic uh
you know a lot of other people in the
family so it's one of those things you
just kind of have to watch obviously
being overweight was a factor but many
other things are as well and you know
when blood sugar is out of whack you're
more tired easily uh you're more
susceptible to infections of different
sorts and you know we were trying
different things and fairly unsuccessful
and over this uh last year it kind of
came to a head and eventually I went on
medication for it and that has been
helping out quite a bit but you know
it's it's still something I have to keep
an eye on and no doubt it does take a
toll uh to some degree reducing stress
getting good sleep staying hydrated
eating the right things getting
consistent exercise all of those are
very important for that uh there's
there's you know coid is not good for
for diabetes or diabetics uh so that
probably played a role as well um I've
had some you know various illnesses over
the years some sinus infections I
actually had uh what was uh most likely
a staff infection that I had to take
antibiotics for I was on some pretty
high-powered antibiotics for quite a
while and that kind of messes with you
as well it wears you down you know you
got the whole gut hell thing going on
and uh recently the biggest challenge
has been that well you know it's been
about close to two months now I started
feeling this pain consistent pain in my
side and after about a week and a half
of that you know uh my wife was like you
better go to the doctor and get this
checked out so so I did and they were
like oh that sounds like gallbladder
issues very common for people in America
it's actually one of the most common
surgeries to take the gallbladder out
and I know a lot of people that have had
it out and so they sent me to get it
checked out you know get a um scan of it
an ultrasound first and um they found
that I had some stones and what they
call sludge so you know it's not working
100%
and uh then you know they said if if
anything changes in pain level or stuff
like that then make sure that you go to
urgent care or the ER it did one day I
had to cancel my night class went in it
was kind of itchy and pain level had
increased they did another scan and and
the the guy said well you need to get it
out uh sooner or later it's got to come
out and I was like H okay you know then
I already had lined up a surgical
consult and I'm not going to go into
great detail about that suffice it to
say the guy that uh I was schedule to
see was not a a people person and uh we
didn't really see eye to eye in the uh
consult itself and I was okay with that
because I don't really care too much
about personalities when it comes to
those sorts of matters but he actually
misreported things that I told him in
his notes and so that tells me that he's
not paying great attention to detail we
look later and not a not a a lot of good
reviews um so I I have another consult
scheduled with somebody who's got great
reviews uh end of November and
eventually you know it'll get uh
resolved one way or the other and you
know you can change your diet a bit
eliminate fried foods and things that
aggravate it but there's not that much
you can do so I've been in more or less
constant lowgrade pain for now about
five six
weeks and you know that's no fun it kind
of tires you out it saps you it also
kind of messes with your pancreas so I
get some pain on the other side and you
know overall it places stress on your
system so you know all these things kind
of work hand inand or don't work hand in
hand you might say right they exacerbate
each other recently I've started having
pain uh up here and I went in to have
that checked out and they they said well
it's inflammation of the cartilage in
your your ribs and you know as it turns
out I I injured that
area about close to 15 years ago I
bruised a rib a long time ago so that's
probably what's going on and you know
this is all manageable with some you
know over-the-counter
medications for for pain relief but it
it it takes a toll on you over a while
and it's a constant reminder that your
body is aging um the other thing that's
been going on which is kind of a um a
good thing but also you know not so
great ever since coid I've I've had some
pains like every single day waking me up
generally in my my legs generally in my
knees my quads my hamstrings and what
are called the IT band and you know I
stretch and I do various exercises and
it helps out a bit so I went to uh PT
physical therapy and the uh physical
therapist gave me some things to do and
they're they're helping a bit but you
know it's still pain but all of this is
kind of low grade stuff except when it
isn't and that's not all that common but
it's a constant challenge to to deal
with and so there's kind of some
circular effects we could say on this
and what I mean by circular is the
things that would actually make it
better get a little bit harder to do
when you're dealing with these sorts of
things so it takes more effort more
discipline to stay on track you know the
all of it makes me more more easily
tired sometimes I get hit with just like
a wall of fatigue that was H something
that was happening to me after coid and
it wasn't bad for a while while but with
the pain sometimes I'm you know bushed
by 8:00 at night which normally wouldn't
be the case for me usually I'm I'm up
until you know about 11 o'clock
oftentimes working but um I I don't
think I could keep up that pace quite
anymore um it's the biggest issue is
that it becomes harder to do exercise
consistently I'd love to get to the gym
three days a week and lift weights and
then do other stuff on the other days
but it doesn't always happen part of it
is due to my my schedule I'm teaching a
lot of classes and they're at uh times
that are kind of inconvenient for
working out uh because the gym closes
ever since Co and reopening they closes
earlier as well um so there's that going
on um but I still do get you know some
some exercise in so that's good I have
fallen behind over time on various work
on um projects that I've got on
correspondence I'm I'm quite far behind
in my correspondence from the last
several weeks because of busyness and
classes but also because of dealing with
all this uh medical stuff the
gallbladder issues the other pain issues
and and things like that and so you know
a lot of
people when they go through setbacks
like this they can wind up getting
dismayed despondent even depressed and I
I have I'm somebody who's you know
suffered from depression in the past um
I'm fortunate in that I was able to get
off of
anti-depressants in in part through uh
you know developing better perspective
through applying philosophy particularly
stoic and Aristotelian and platonic
philosophy and some other things and you
know doing doing what we call exercises
but also you know other way of improving
my my life and therefore my mood and
it's understandable when you get sick or
if you're dealing with like chronic pain
or conditions that are just not going to
get better that you know you feel some
despair or sadness or even grief you
know grief for what you could do and
can't do anymore um pain of course
irritability all of those sort of things
and those make it hard harder for you to
you know carry out and conduct the
things that are important for your life
maintain relationships get your work
done all of those sorts of matters but
you know what I do is I I remind myself
that okay I didn't get everything done
that I wanted to do and I'm behind on
some things and I some of the things
that I have been doing I didn't do to
the absolute best of my you know High
performing ability that I've been known
for in the past but I did accomplish
some things you know I've this this year
this Academic Year uh this rather
calendar year I have taught seven uh
courses at Marquette actually it might
be eight and uh yeah it's eight uh for
each semester Marquette and Milwaukee
Institute of Art and Design um you know
I'm not doing the best but I'm still
probably in the 75th percentile as far
as like quality and getting things
accomplished I also taught an online
class that people participated on
through the study with Sadler Academy I
gave a lot of talks um some of them
online some of them in person uh most
recently I gave a talk at the
International stoicon Conference and
that's you know kind of a cool thing for
for me to do uh I did also finish a
massive project that I've been working
on for almost 10 years called half hour
Hegel that ended up being over
370 commentary videos and I I saw that
through and brought that to a successful
close I started
volunteering at um almost home cat
shelter which required me to do not just
show up and and start doing that but to
go through training both online and
iners and I've been you know going there
I've also been helping out with grants
for them as well
you know and I've also been making sure
that I get to spend time um not just at
home but you know doing things out and
about with my wife and my my kids and
you know friends and colleagues and
family members when I get to see them so
all of that is you know it's not nothing
and it's way more than than nothing and
I remind myself of that and if you're
struggling with similar stuff you know
you can remind yourself that you didn't
just do nothing you did what you were
capable of doing and it might not have
been what you were capable of doing 10
years ago or even a year ago or a month
ago but that doesn't mean that it's
valueless or no good or just not up to
standards or something like that it's
it's important to I think remind
yourself of that so I've been you know
doing that my wife is very helpful
because she also helps to remind me
of that as well and I do that for for
her occasionally probably she does that
more than I do and so this leads to
thinking about some useful reminders and
so these are the things that I remind
myself of every so often and they could
be helpful for you if you're struggling
with similar circumstances or maybe
they'll be helpful for you down the line
if you're nice and you got a nice young
body that's more or less chugging along
doing just fine well give it 10 20 30
years and maybe this will be helpful for
you so you know one of the things that
I've actually found it's very basic that
is quite helpful to remind yourself of
this comes you know officially from
stoicism where it's called the dichotomy
of control and modern stoicism there's
no actual name for it in uh ancient
stoicism it's it's a preconception a
prolis that epicus just talks about what
is up to us what is not up to us the you
know what we control what we don't
control what we have some contribution
to what we can at best just influence
and our our body stoics remind us is one
of those things you know you can be as
fit as you like and eat you know
completely healthy and get hit by the
bus tomorrow or die of a heart attack
like that famous runner back I think in
the 70s or 80s who was like you know uh
the super guy and killed over while he
was mid jog right um You you don't
control your genetics you don't control
the environment to you know any great
extent that you're living in you can try
to set up your schedule so that you get
exercise so you get decent sleep you can
try to you know eat healthy as much as
you you can in our environment where
we're constantly bombarded with adver
advertisement for unhealthy food and you
got to kind of like think a lot to to
figure out what actually isn't uh full
of stuff that's bad for you in the food
that we can buy you can do all that
stuff but ultimately all you're doing is
you know the best that you can do with
what's not in your control doesn't mean
you should just like say oh well screw
it then nothing I can do about this
because you know we're giving our bodies
to live in as long as we can so you know
that's important I've also found it very
helpful
personally to think about other people
like myself so we're thinking about
other public
Scholars um who at certain points in
time because of health reasons or family
reasons or whatever it was had to step
back a bit and they still did some of
their work
but they they said well I just can't do
this over here and you know I could give
you plenty of examples I'll just give
you one Alistair McIntyre who um you
know had committed to Leading The
arasmus Institute faculty seminar that
that's how I met him and became you know
uh colleagues and and friends and uh got
to know what kind of person he was and
he was he was in you know kind of rough
health and he was kind of keeping it to
himself but he couldn't do all the
things that he wanted to do with us in
the seminar that he would have done what
were he feeling better and down the line
he was feeling better right and then he
went back to doing the kinds of stuff
that he did he didn't stop working all
together but he paired back and so you
know I think about examples like that
and I'm like well if it's good enough
for him you know somebody who I greatly
admire and emulate well that's good
enough for me over here as well um and I
think it's also important
to keep in mind something I've already
talked about a little bit that not being
able to do everything doesn't mean that
you're not doing anything even if all
you can do is just one thing like send
one email a day that's something it's
not nothing and it's not crap by
comparison to what you were able to do
in the past because it's relative to
what our capacities what our uh you know
what we can do before we get too tired
or too distracted by pain or whatever it
happens to be what it is that we're able
to do in the moment that's good if we
can do something obviously it's you know
if you've made some commitments and you
can't follow through on them that
doesn't feel good that kind of sucks
right and it sucks for the people that
you committed to but that's what happens
sometimes and it doesn't mean that you
become a bad person or you're lazy or
not measuring up to your potential or
whatever other people might might say
about you you know what you're capable
of and so long as you're you don't even
have to put in 100% effort every day so
long as you can put in
80% I think that's good you know
consistent 80% effort beats uh
idealistic 100% effort that's
unsustainable any day um I also think
it's important to
maintain a realistic perspective about
health and your body don't be a
perfectionist about health you know you
need to have the a degree of Health that
will let you accomplish the things that
you want to do within reason right and
your body you're not going to reverse
aging you're not going to reverse
whatever crazy damage you did to it in
your teens and 20s you know doing stupid
things right uh you know hearing loss in
in my case I've been living with tenius
for however it's pronounced tinitus or
something like that for uh decades
because I was stupid when I was young
and when I was in the Army we blew stuff
up and we didn't put our hearing
protection in we shot our you know
rifles and you know worked with loud
machinery and I went to concerts where
you know speakers are right in your ears
and I listen to loud music with my
headphones
on no changing that right not going to
fix that um you got to live with it and
so you know maintaining a realistic
perspective I think can be quite helpful
and then you know making sure that you
look at uh rest and relaxation and
whatever counts as rejuvenation for
yourself not just as something that you
let yourself have after you've been good
and you've done all your work for the
day and not just as something kind of
negative because you're not doing stuff
but as as a positive good you know and
this is where I think ancient philosophy
can be quite helpful because instead of
saying we got to be productive
productive productive all the time they
recognize that rest and enjoyment and
relaxation are part of the good life and
so you know those of us who are very
driven those of us who've developed
habits of productivity and you might say
mindsets of it sometimes we got to do
some reminding ourself that it can be
okay to take a nap or read a book that
you're not going to be doing a a you
know video or a book review or whatever
on or teaching uh you know that we do
need to as they say smell the flowers
and sometimes just look at the flowers
for five minutes of dead time what what
real called Solitude you know in in his
letters to a young poet so anyway those
are my Reflections that's what's going
on with me if this is helpful for you
that's great if it's just kind of uh
entertaining that's good too uh if you
uh you know have any thoughts or
something like that not medical advice
because I'm not looking for that
especially from people who don't
actually know me um but anything else go
ahead and leave it in the comments and
we can you know see where things go from
there